hey everybody it's me and I'm back from
the dead this is unbelievable my tour
solo is on pause because the Impractical
Jokers national tour has started the
arena tour tickets are on sale for the
first leg of it right now at impractical
jokerslive.com we're coming to Reading
Pennsylvania we're coming to uh Stony
Brook we're coming to Pittsburgh Camden
New Jersey Boston we're coming to
Charleston South Carolina Charlotte
North Carolina Waterloo New York uh
Washington DC Niagara Falls Newark
Wallingford Belmont Park we're playing
that UBS Arena and the Prudential arena
in Jersey Island Milwaukee Rosemont
Seattle Portland I mean guys Utah Denver
Arlington Austin Sugar Land Columbus
Cleveland Detroit Minneapolis Des Moines
Kansas City I'm getting tired Nashville
Indianapolis and St Louis that's just
what's announced right now and it's all
on sale right now we're revving up right
now the show's gonna be a blast we
haven't been out in years hope to see
you there in practicaljokerslive.com
once again I never promised You a Rose
Garden bringing the show down to Austin
Texas January 13th and 14th at the
Vulcan and then New York again Levittown
New York at Governors January 20th and
21st come and check out all these shows
more being added all the time stay tuned
get all your Show tickets and all your
show info joeinfo.com also please check
out we'll see you in hell my movie
podcast with Pat Walsh we are over at
we'll see uh I'm sorry we're at
patreon.com
wsiyhpodcast you can get all the new
episodes there and the back catalog is
available online wherever you get your
podcasts and finally Joey Rose's my barn
sandwich shop is now open seven days a
week at 11 30 a.m every day drinks and
sandwiches all day long come through
thank you for the support we've turned a
year old I can't believe we made it this
is amazing thank you guys we couldn't
have done it without you come see us and
if you want info about the barn sandwich
shop
joeyrosesnyc.com that thank you taste
buds they coming to the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two Fool's gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds hey Tasties welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buds we're back the buds are
back and today we're battling back in
town birds are Back in Town today we're
battling happy hour versus brunch we'll
get to it later we'll reveal who's who
you can probably guess at this point
who's who but yeah you can guess but uh
but we'll get into that later
but we will get into it did you see
um
did you see my outfit look too tight no
no because it feels tight enough didn't
I wouldn't say that at all
it is a little hot in here though I had
lost a lot of weight fasting and then I
stopped fasting and I gained it right
back uh tell me about the fasting what
was the rule I was doing the eight hour
intermittent fasting what was your radar
window that you were eating I was eating
usually three to eleven PM so you didn't
eat you didn't eat until 3 pm to begin
your day yeah is that because your your
current schedule because of the bars
like you wake up by like noon it just I
don't know for some reason it just
worked for me and uh and it also allowed
me
you know that if I did have a later I
could eat later yeah
um and if I and honestly if I wasn't
doing anything if I was just spending
the day at home
I liked that I had up until like 10 P.M
to have a snack and stuff so she
everybody had no pressure did
intermittent fasting while I was dead I
I lost dude I was down to 199. how many
how much did you lose off of it like 16
pounds in how long
it seemed like days
[Laughter]
one one day you ate in one eight hour
window yeah it like it was fast this is
like breaking news but have you seen the
new weight loss drug that'll make you
lose 22 percent of your body fat in a
couple weeks give it to me please that
can't be healthy as we all know um
did trials you lose 22 is it FDA
approved well I want it I don't know how
much is that going to be 11 trade a
month is the treatment
for diabetes so I can't imagine if you
don't have diabetes what it would cost
you
oh so okay so just for that can you let
me let me see the the little I think uh
scroll up a little bit
a clinical trial found that a high dose
of
Thursday which was previously approved
for diabetes treatment help patients
lose an average of 22.5 percent of their
body weight
if we could make a note of this so I can
call my doctor immediately got you man
scroll down let's read this I'm I'm this
peaked my interest here watch the whole
doc on it and people are keeping the
weight off there's no bounce back how
long did it take you to bounce back
me yeah I didn't bounce back to 216. I
bounced back I'm like at 205 or six now
God love you it's not terrible but it's
like it's still it was still a gain back
because like I just
I just went off of it for like a but I
went off it for a week anything that's
not a lifestyle is gonna have bounce
back yeah and I and I I do when I went
off of it I mean like I was like it was
like
the week of Christmas through New Year's
I was like you know drinking I'm I'm
going out for steak I was down 18 18
pounds and in the last
the last like week and a half plus
I I just have like maybe two weeks just
started smoking again and just oh
smoking weed yeah no no no and just
eating all the holiday Foods I'm baking
cakes like you know at home but now I'm
going like now I said I'm waiting for
all the leftovers to leave my home from
like the holiday
I should just start immediately but I'm
waiting and then I'm just I'm going not
only am I going in
firm but I think I'm gonna do the
intermittent as well I gotta tell you
though they got me on that Lipitor
and you kind of does it you kind of you
kind of I mean you're not supposed to
start your app no but you just kind of
look at it as an excuse to worry about
high cholesterol anymore you're like
that's this this is doing all the heavy
lifting
oh so you're like well now I have a I
have the map no I don't do that I don't
do that but I eat I I was so strict on
the diet for months and now that I've
slipped off of it I'm kind of like wow
the Lipitor is probably doing most of
the lifting for him yeah I'm sure that
crumb cake will help probably not oh
a new drug that could have far-reaching
impact and billions in sales is likely
to be approved of weight loss by the
Food and Drug Administration this year
the drug made by U.S pharmaceutical
company Eli Lilly that's the one that
got in the into the thing on Twitter
I think Eli Lilly was the company that
was the first famous
fake verified account under Elon Musk
cost them like a billion dollars or
something so it was yeah some crazy
amount of money uh higher doses it's
been proven to be highly effective for
weight loss by reducing food intake and
appetite and improving how the body
breaks down sugar and fat a clinical
trial found that a high dose of
this thing help patients lose 52 pounds
or an average of 22 and a half percent
of their body weight after approved by
the FDA it's predicted to hit a record
of 48 billion in sales
well so we should should we invest in
this right now
it's unlikely most people will be able
to receive the prescription medication
taken by injection in the thigh stomach
or arm through insurance company so you
got to inject yourself with this
do you have to do it daily
all right
13 000 annually
1100 a month all right would you do that
doctors criticize trend of using
diabetes drugs for weight loss people
who need these drugs can't get them oh
geez well that's but I thought that the
whole thing was that they're gonna be
putting them out would you if it was if
you weren't taking it away from a
diabetic person would you do this I
can't imagine injecting myself with
something wait scroll back up pimp well
but if the doctor injected you I want to
see what Andy Cohen said
we don't know
right there
Elon Musk early of the month
used with Govi for his recent slim down
okay Andy Cohen also tweeted about the
growing popularity
I guess it's one of these
editor something
all right okay you wouldn't let your
doctor inject you
you're that scared of needles so I go it
just feels weird
you tell me your doctor's here right now
you go Sal I'm gonna inject you in the
thigh with something and you're going to
lose 22 percent of your body fat no if
he's gonna tell me he has to inject me
how often though I go to the doctor once
a week and get a shot in the thigh
yeah let's let's say It's weekly
I would one million percent do I was
saying that 100 there's no no bad
effects
it seems to be what they're saying it is
100 no health effects nothing that
you're sacrificing or you know that
right then yeah promise you I promise
you this has already been secretly being
used in Hollywood oh without it there's
no way it's not well actually sound
misdelivered King controversy
oh yeah they talked Chris talked about
it so much I feel like on hey babe I
don't wanna
retread I mean I'm not dismissing it I
didn't know who it was until it came out
now he's being sued out of existence
since then because people bought his
diet based on his marketing I downloaded
his manual
yeah it was free
wait why it was free because I was like
so impressed by him this guy walks
around eating [ __ ] bone marrow how
did you act how did you how did you know
who the liver King was before on
Instagram and I was like before this
controversy yeah way before and I was
like man this guy's wild Rosa eating raw
meat I'd love that I love you know me
with me dude I was like [ __ ] is this
like a real thing this guy looks like
he's gonna die I have a heart attack and
he was so positive and everything and I
was like look healthy to me he doesn't
look healthy the first crack in the damn
was I saw Rogan watching him for the
first time and Rogan went that is not a
natural body and I was like oh [ __ ]
that's not good press
and I was like all right maybe this is
not what it says what he's saying it is
was that him eating a liver yeah he eats
oh he's called the liver King and he
eats raw liver of what animal he eats
raw meat period
yeah no this video of him eating raw
liver
put it pull up a video of him eating a
royal liver he eats he just eats raw
meat but that can't be that can't be
healthy and he was insinuating he was
insinuating that by virtue of him eating
the raw meat he's got a whole lifestyle
of things that you do to look like that
and then it came out that he was on
steroids that wasn't part of it and he
apologized and said he [ __ ] part of
his lifestyle uh sunning your butthole
and taint wasn't that part of it he had
a lot of weird [ __ ] there was like the
ice plunge thing like the cold bath
every morning and you know it was a lot
how do you Sun your taint very carefully
yeah but this is oh wait wait wait so
how did it come out it says he admits it
did he come out on his own or was he
called out and then he had to he got
called out and then he emails leaked
because like everything else in this
country a rat leaked something out you
know what I mean like his emails leaked
I can't even pick a team in the argument
because it's it's you know he lied and
then there's a role wow
oh wow
oh God
he called himself the liver King yeah
and that that's what his his Instagram
is liver King yeah and he eats like raw
bone marrow and [ __ ] and he has a big
following because of the things he eats
and because he was trying to be like a
lifestyle environmental supplements
no I don't think he was selling
supplements did he just drink a cup of
blood okay yeah he drinks blood
yeah anyway all right I didn't know that
that was safe I didn't know you could do
that so what raw meat yeah I mean I've
had Carpaccio but yeah but but I I don't
think you could just take a bite out of
a whole liver
ah I drink blood and [ __ ] like I'm sure
it's got to be of a certain quality you
know but
I don't you know that never I hear you I
I guess you're getting a whole liver
like that the butcher
yeah yeah butcher yeah yeah well I
wouldn't probably knows a guy that has a
fight to a liver on a for fun cooked
liver is pretty I don't know sometimes
you get a craving for cooked liver my
mom used to make it when I was a kid you
ever had liver no liver and onions no
yeah it's like a famous wow no yeah yeah
I mean not a lot of no it's not no no
it's actually a cheaper dish it was made
people made it a lot because it was it
was cheap uh wait wait people made a lot
liver and onions is it was a very
Americanized in like the 70s
probably
I I don't know anyone who ate liver and
onions oh we used to eat it in my house
growing up is it like a rural thing
I don't know liver and onions so I've
seen it on me those are the two
components in the dish yes so you cook a
liver look just look it's like fried
liver with onions fried onions wow but
there's is it good
it's not as a kid you would eat it
without any can as a kid I actually
loved it and then I got I I liked some
weird [ __ ] when I was getting then I got
older and I didn't like it anymore not
because of the flavor the flavor is fine
the consistent there's a certain
consistency of it that I don't like
anymore so it's a little mealy it's the
best way you don't like the consistency
of carrot cake but you love the
consistency of liver as a child well
because as I said I'm a man not a Nana
you said you liked it when you were
little yeah I was a man then too all
right I've always been a man not a Nana
yeah I said carrot cake was different
onions that's the most Nana dish I've
ever heard of I said carrot cake was
Nana food liver and onions is Nana food
listen what do you want for me I I want
the truth we're not here to talk about
liver we're not here to talk about the
liver King we're to talk about happy
hour versus brunch so let's go hey folks
this episode is sponsored by loamy by
Pila Lomi by Pila what is loamy what is
Pila what are they doing well they are
helping you with your struggle with
composting uh as somebody who lives in
the city I have never been able to do
any composting why because they didn't
have a yard and I couldn't have a
composting
uh you know unit uh but what I like that
that what's going on with this product
is you got yourself a countertop
composter very very very cool uh and
here's why that's cool
I take a lot of garbage out which again
living in the city is a pain in the
behind uh and a lot of that garbage is
food waste if I had a way to compost my
food waste I would save myself a lot of
trips back and forth up and down the
stairs uh with the trash bags I'd also
save myself on the spending I'm doing on
trash bags and also I'd just be doing a
better overall thing with my waist
period so loamy helps me out it allows
me to turn the food scraps into dirt
with the push of a button loamy is a
countertop again electric composter and
it's turning your scraps into dirt in
under four hours no smell and it runs
very very very quietly which is also
great uh look I can't say enough about
how much I enjoy throwing out less
garbage uh and also if you want to get
into a global sense of this thing that
means less is going into the landfills
you're not producing methane pain and
instead you're turning your waste into
nutrient-rich dirt that you can use to
feed your plants I grow herbs myself so
you can use it to do that whatever the
hell you want maybe just like dirt I
don't know that's on you it's not my
business anyway you want to start making
a positive environmental impact or just
make cleanup after dinner a lot easier
loamy is perfect for you head to
loamy.com tastebuds use the promo code
taste buds you're gonna get 50 off your
loamy that's 50 bucks off when you head
to lomi.com taste buds and use promo
code taste buds at checkout food waste
is gross let loamy save you a cold trip
out to the garbage can what's up guys we
have a new sponsor on the show called
Bessie they are primarily well for me
they're shoes and they're waterproof
shoes and I got a pair and they were so
comfortable
like as comfortable as I mean I'm a
sneakerhead they were as comfortable as
my most comfortable pair of shoes and I
like them so much that I went ahead and
got a pair of boots from them called the
cloud burst
and I cannot wait to wear these things
these are like all weather shoes it's a
hundred percent waterproof and uh yeah I
mean just so comfortable
um psyched about it uh they're like a
game changer for me because I need
something when I leave the house every
day for work that is going to deal with
any type of weather if it rains if it
doesn't they breathe really nice too a
lot of support goes on my feet all the
time so if you guys are in the same
situation you're gonna like the the
shoes
um you know when your shoes get wet and
you have soggy cold grocery all day they
prevent that from ever happening
literally 100 waterproof the great shoes
for the winter
um so the cloudburst is it's an all
rubber winter boot built into the
sneaker it's 100 waterproof not water
resistant
um it's warm but it's lighter than most
boots uh they have a very rugged rubber
outside sole that gives extra grip and
wet conditions and added lining inside
for extra warmth in the cold they slip
on and off too because this part is kind
of like
completely malleable so I love it made
from dymatex which is a super soft knit
material that keeps your feet warm in
the cold but cool in the warmer months
it doesn't feel like it should be
waterproof but it absolutely is super
comfortable and breathable uh that's all
the stuff that I I love about the shoe
so right now of course there are other
styles to choose from too but you can go
to
um the website to check it out vessies
are uh Really Gonna Be Mine and Joe's
go-to shoes at our door we had a very
serious conversation about it check them
out in the link vesi.com taste buds for
a pair of your Vesti shoes and if you
use the code taste buds you'll get 15
off your entire order check them out
let's go to the battle all right ready
yeah salty or I love you whatever you
want man no give me some input here
[Laughter]
all right let's go right yeah save it
for the salty all right it's starting to
get salty it's starting to get salty
it's not even salty
you're gonna keep getting covered over
and over and over because
of your lifestyle and you think that
you're just above it all you go down and
you hang with these people unprotected
all the time you're getting home at 11
o'clock eating dinner at 11 o'clock at
night all right mingling with all these
hangers on at the bar
you're the only person I know that's had
covered how many times you had covered
now twice that we know of twice you know
how many times you told me I'm sick it's
probably not coveted and then you just
didn't even test no I did test that's
[ __ ] I always test I didn't take a
PCR I took Rapids and I stayed in and
isolated you're gonna keep getting
covered huh You're Gonna keep getting
coven because you think you're really an
insult you think that you're above it
and The Company You Keep and the
lifestyle you have it's your lifestyle
is covet prone if if that's not an alarm
for you I don't know what it is I'm
trying to wake you up this isn't really
an insult you were on a better track
when you said I always get on your
nerves today I thought you're gonna run
with that no but I just feel like you're
gonna keep getting cold tell me where
I'm getting on your nerves today give me
something to [ __ ] spice me up a
little bit here because you give a [ __ ]
if I get covered again this poor
attitude and you're abrasive your
abrasive commentary good good ready yes
starting to get salty it's starting to
get something exciting itself
chin
now do it again and commit to it no is
that your is that what you're
complaining no it's time to get
something it's time to get something
it's time to get salty listen to me you
have the intention span of a [ __ ] net
you want to sit here you want to sit
here and watch Tick Tock videos I'll
tell you what save that [ __ ] for hey
babe all right because I've seen the
complaints about it in the reviews
this isn't a [ __ ] show where we watch
videos something crazy
I just tried I just I just started last
week just to try for my ADHD I tried
very low dose uh I tried Adderall okay
so this is my first week on Adderall and
I'm charting how it's going and I'm
taking my blood pressure and all that
stuff and I don't know if it's for me or
not that's what I need it's another pill
but listen yeah listen he thinks I have
no attention span right now and I'm
actually on Adderall so how [ __ ]
boring is he that I'm on Adderall and I
can't pay attention to him how boring
you don't mean to you
try painting khakis
you don't need to be on Adderall it's
making you Twitchy and looking all over
the place because you don't need to be
on it
might be talking about I got news for
you you don't have ADHD I've never met
an obsessive [ __ ] like you in my life
all you do is focus in on stuff no
that's bad it's bad I went is it bad I'm
tested all right I'm Doctor introduce
your your ADHD to our next taste buds
thread how about that bring a little HD
ADHD to that where we're trying to
figure out what battle to do for 28
[ __ ] breaks versus happy hour Jesus
Christ you chose happy hour and that
links right into my my saltiness of you
guys you're you're a happy hour guy
you're a identity now is sometimes
attached to happy hour
what happy hour with people coming oh
I'm sorry I opened the bar where people
go it's amateur it should be called
Amateur hour happy hour okay the only
people who need to run to happy hour are
people that need a drink for two dollars
that need to wash away their day because
they hate their life or they hate their
job and that need human contact they
can't find it elsewhere it's happy hour
happy hour is just good PR talk yeah
it's just good PR happy hours for all
the people convening together like we
need something and we need to fast can I
talk to you you're as miserable as me
you have a one dollar shot you have this
sack yeah you have the sack to say this
and that's why you're getting your car
hold on a second that's where you're
getting your covered yeah you have the
sack to say this about happy hour when
you want to talk about five people
sitting around the table at 11 30 a.m
they don't like each other they don't
like the meals they don't like the
hybrid menu they gotta drink orange
juice mixed with champagne to get
through this [ __ ] meal
foreign
Bloody Mary your whole hour is comprised
of that my whole hours
my whole hour is fun you're you're get
together of brunch is the saddest most
Force it's where it's what people do
after they lose the fire they think
they're having fun so they go to a
[ __ ] they go to a half-assed Bistro
at 11 o'clock in the morning and sit
there and have to drink
so you're telling me that on a weekend
getting up early and going against
social go and get a meal that is
reserved for usually Saturdays and
Sundays it's a different menu to go take
it to the best menu take advantage of
that menu and have a breakfast lunch
hybrid on a nice weekend afternoon with
company and maybe even have a little Day
drink a little just a little little
drink oh Rosary that's why it's always
bottomless right they have most of us
just offered I don't go to you they have
to don't attach it hold on don't they
have just the [ __ ] let me tell you
how much it is
that go to brunch
no no no no I'm not talking about who
utilizes bottomless whatever they have
to do that to get people to walk through
the door at that ungodly hour to sit and
eat a menu of [ __ ] they can't get rid of
ungodly hour ungodly hour 10 to 3 P.M
nobody wants to be there on Sunday
nobody wants to be there no it starts
two hours later nobody wants to be there
everybody would rather be watching
football in a bar with wings for people
in your happy hour is designed only
first and foremost the invention of it
is to get people in at an ungodly hour
right after work because they need a
drink and you want to get people in for
the whole night your whole thing is just
a a stunt to get people in the door
that's not true that's why happy hour
exists and you're telling me that people
going to get a meal and having a Mimosa
they both exist for the same reason but
I am telling you something but you the
first thing you said about brunch was
it's filled with people who don't like
like each other you're editorializing
it's completely arbitrary that's not
brunch
the table don't like each other
should be called Brunch colon the meal
for acquaintances that's what it should
be called that's a coffee you go out and
you get a coffee that's what it should
be called it's the meal for a queen I
actually love sitting down a nice brunch
on a beautiful day with friends getting
out getting a meal and what's better
than kicking a kicking a Friday night
off with a happy hour dude we're gonna
start at happy hour oh stop it's amateur
it's not Amateur hour it's not Amateur
hour most bars it is you go with
bartender for a decade you go in you eat
wings you eat chicken fingers
you have a great time slammed at happy
hour because people want to get loaded
within two hours for five dollars that's
the type of people that run to the happy
hour by and large okay the thing you
said about brunch I'm sorry you gotta
take that back no it's not a good
defense you go to brunch where everyone
hates each other her nobody likes the
food what kind of an argument is that
that's such [ __ ] the brunch menu
sucks it's three things from breakfast
and three things from lunch and you
don't really want any of them I want all
of them and I think it's great no it's
always it's always like the turkey club
pancakes it's three it's the [ __ ] nobody
[ __ ] wants that's not true at all yes
it is it's the [ __ ] people want and
that's why it's only offered on the week
it's either that or it's some stupid
[ __ ] like over-the-top breakfast
thing like we we made uh we made pumpkin
pie pancakes come on in and get them at
breakfast oh God it sounds delicious
it's awful I hate brunch you so you hate
so much lunch and you hate a combination
no uh I like breakfast it's my least
favorite meal of the day I love lunch at
brunch you have lunch items you have
breakfast items and then you have items
that are combined you have three of each
and no you don't stop saying stuff like
The Limited menu stop saying brunch is a
limited menu
I want you to Google this question right
now and I want you to phrase it exactly
like this why do brunch menus have
limited items I want you to Google nuts
that's common sense it's because
it's because dude it's a full menu
limited no no this is that's that's just
limited menus in in general menu bro I
don't know where you go for your brunch
all right
just like how many items are on a brunch
menu
it's always a truncated menu why would
that come back with a result how could
you say how many items are on a brunch
menu what kind of question is that
that's absurd what do you mean how many
drinks are on a happy hour menu Google
it pimp let me know what kind of stupid
ass thing I'm trying to prove a point
that every time I see a brunch menu it
is a limited amount of items menu
excites me a brunch menu exactly because
I can have breakfast I can have lunch or
I could have these cool dishes that are
made specifically for brunch that aren't
on them
what are these hybrid dishes you dumbass
you're talking as if it takes a
scientist to figure out to put eggs next
to a club
you're going up you're going for brunch
in some [ __ ] places bro we live in
New York City we put we put uh French
toast on the burger it's a hybrid brunch
thing please oh it sucks please come on
in nickel Wings yes
oh five dollar pictures and and quarter
Wings sounds like a great a bottomless
Mimosa sounds like a place you go with
your boys
he has a problem with but a five dollar
picture of beer he doesn't have a
problem no I am telling you the only
people I have never seen people that
truly like one another make brunch plans
if you said to me let's go to brunch I
go now let's go to dinner instead I go
to brunch with people all the time it's
a fun thing to do on the weekend it gets
you out of the house you never know
where it's gonna lead at you it might
you might want to go out after that it's
a fun meal it's not as early as
breakfast it's not as late as lunch it's
right smack in the Middle East you're
done with enough time to do something
else you go with good company the vibe
is good I like a brunch it's and it's a
Once an occasion effect it cuts right
into lunch every day at five o'clock
come drink your [ __ ] face off blare
the music and and spend as little money
as possible get as drunk as possible
because we need you there is I'll tell
you I'll tell
and I'll tell you I'll tell you what
happy hour did for me throughout my life
when I had a nine to five it solidified
my friendships and relationships with my
colon my co-workers if my co-workers
would have said let's all meet up on
Sunday for brunch I would have said [ __ ]
off I take two days off from you people
when they said let's all go to happy
hour out of work after work today we had
a [ __ ] blast together we found bars
that weren't crowded that still like how
many hours and we had a great for the
most part it's Amateur hour and it's
funny that you're a big thing to boy
happy hour is great is that it
solidifies your relationships with your
co-workers I didn't say my big how's
that my big thing that's you just said
that's like no I said
it's one thing that it's done for me
that I've enjoyed it's insane that
brunch will have both breakfast and
lunch items on it amongst other more
creative things okay give me one of the
creative things but you hate it but I'm
still waiting for one of these creative
things tell me one of them since you go
to no no no no no no since you go to
brunch all the time
all the time you go you don't remember
any of these amazing dishes I go to
brunch failure often okay you don't but
you would say I go to a bunch a few
times a year okay but you don't oh few
times a year is all the time first of
all I mean but wait you don't remember I
called I called that I go to brunch a
minimum of five times a year five times
a year sometimes it's all the time
sometimes more sometimes not even once a
month you go to my you go to brunch not
even buying money I'm giving you the
bare minimum and you said all the time
there's been a year that I went to
brunch
at least once a month okay if not more
it's I'm just giving you I'm just being
honest it's nowhere near us how I feel
about people listen it doesn't matter
you were being dishonest when you said
all the time that's all but my point is
this I mean like I go to brunch often
enough there's times where I go once
every few weeks okay okay I don't happy
hours [ __ ] every day at five o'clock
that's you know that's the opposite I
don't go to happy hour every day at five
o'clock
happy brunches every weekend what are
you talking about that was every day a
lot of bars don't have happy hour on for
Saturday or Sunday they don't do it
right they have brunch
[Laughter]
which is a nice way to get people in
that aren't looking to get [ __ ] faced
potentially that's all people do is get
shit-faced at brunch that's what they do
that's not true they start their day
drinking at brunch that's what some
people use for that's the sole reason
for happy hour oh no I like to have good
conversation I like to read a paper I
like to go sit outside in the sun
you were shoveling days of the week you
were shoveling such piles of horseshit
right now it's unreal I mean it truly is
getting crazy because you're crazy to
say that I asked you one simple question
I'm talking about like brunch like
Instagram
influences well that's what brunch is
always happy okay so then happy hour
brunch for one brunch why it was
invented like original brunch a good old
brunch there was never good old brunch
it was invented to get people in during
off hours by offering them bottomless
mimosas
was coined by British writer guy
Behringer in 1895. he argued that
instead of the post-church early dinner
that was typical in England at the time
there should be a hybrid of reference
and lunch shirt around noon for Saturday
night carousers to enjoy
also me these days happy hours happy
hour home early happy hours were
actually periods of time that doesn't
then that mean then you're supporting
exactly what I'm saying you're going
into to Day drink no no I'm not someone
drinking I'm just the one getting out of
the house to do something on the
earliest Side and being homeless happy
hours my Comforts by evening happy hours
were actually periods of time when naval
ships where Sailors could engage in
relaxing activities in order to relieve
themselves engaging and relaxing
activities drinking yeah sounds like my
thing my thing had a purpose I worked at
a bar for 10 years and we were by the
water and the Navy ships docked there
during Fleet week and every year for 10
years during Fleet Week I got hundreds
of sailors in that week and those guys
just come in and they drink like fishes
for no money and they get into fights
and mix them ups and they leave I mean
if you want to sit here and disparage
the troops that's on you I'm not gonna
do it
[Music]
hour on this gay bar we're filled with
Sailors that you read
listen I'm asking you in closing without
looking nothing yeah we gotta go we're
done we got to go to the phones
you can't go to phones right now bro
we're not as how many minutes are we at
no no lights at 35.
I feel like you want to get out of the
battle no I don't want to get out of the
battle I want us we have to I'm trying
to keep us on time here so we have a
good succinct episode hold on a second
don't distract me
my point is I've asked you this without
you guests like this
no never okay never
without looking anything up you wouldn't
want to go okay this Saturday this is my
question this Saturday's gonna be 75
answer my question stop and answer my
question
and answer my question I asked you to
name one off the top of your head of
these wonderful hybrid dishes that
you've had at these many brunches you've
you've attended and you can't do it you
can't do it your point is that from
memory over the years I've gone to
brunch I can't pull up something that I
know is very common in every restaurant
when they do a nice hybrid set it would
give you restaurants that I go to for
brunch you said it was a huge attribute
of brunch it is okay I go to a place
called Shuka okay it's down on mcnugel
used to be called 100 acres it's
meditate Mediterranean inspired so they
have not only they have this staple
breakfast and lunch dishes but they have
all these Mediterranean brunch dishes
that are different than any other place
I've had like what Joe are you is that
we let's pull up the Shuka menu and I'll
tell you you can't name one damn dish
sure they have like a nice fried
halloumi they have a beautiful salad but
they also do stuff like the best
pancakes I've ever had in my life orange
yes ricotta pancakes with fresh whipped
cream and strawberries so much so that I
begged the the the chef for the recipe
and he gave it to me okay so to go there
so you've named brunch you've named
lunch and breakfast items as I said
they're two separate things if you want
to do this okay pull up menus of places
that I've gotten brunch from uh the
reason I'm pointing out and I'll say the
reason I am pointing out that you can't
name one of these for memory is because
I think you're completely full of [ __ ] I
think you've been there I think you've
been to brunch a handful of times in
your life and I think you're talking as
if you're a big brunch supporter and
you're not really that's my point this
is the most crazy thing I've ever heard
in my life it's not that crazy I'm not
I'm not you I'm not lying to you and I'm
not lying to you that I've been to
brunch more than three times in my life
I go to brunch in New York City because
there's so many great brunch spots and I
didn't commit the things I ordered off
the menu don't worry but I'm happy to
tell you the spots I go to Broad chat
and we can look at okay look at them
okay okay let's pull them up uh pull
up the Dutch is a place they go to
brunch at pull up you could pull up
Shuka or two's enough
two's plenty we'll look up two
all right so they got the brunch menu
right there okay starters eggplant dip
with Savory crackers that's not a really
lunch or breakfast thing right I want to
hear about hybrid dishes it doesn't
chilled Island oysters hold on jumbo
shrimp cocktail Crab Louie American
burrata honey nut squash pumpkin seeds
pomegranate kale Caesar watermelon
radish parmesan right Wagyu steak tartar
with capers barbecue pork ribs Kansas
City glaze okay so what you have there
yeah
brunch brunch cornmeal Flapjacks that's
different
hold on a second what the first thing
you named is a breakfast dish it is not
some lunch breakfast hybrid that's what
I'm asking for this menu is not
appeasing to you you said it was gross
you said everyone that goes doesn't what
I said was is you get three lunch things
and three breakfast things okay and you
kept insisting there were these
wonderful Fusion dishes items on the
menu let's count the items on the menu
let's count it go scroll up Scroll up
Scroll up babe okay scroll up one two
three four five six seven go to just a
regular no go to the brunch menu
22 23 24. you see what he's doing 25 20
he's counting outside of the thing that
says brunch 27 full items that's the
brunch menu the thing says brunch the
menu is what's served at brunch now I
want you to count the main dishes at
brunch the menu is what serves I'm not
eating this
eating the juice no it's not so one two
one two three four five six seven eight
I was off by two okay so you're wrong I
was off by two you're wrong I was off by
two right so you're right I also said
you said six I said I know you were off
by 33 I also clarified after I said it
that I was not using a literal number
that what I was saying was you get a
handful of breakfast I disagree with you
more and I have still not seen anything
to disregard that you said when you go
to brunch there's six things to choose
from this menu I was 27 food items now I
don't give a full sound I don't nobody
watches
I don't give a [ __ ] about the appetizer
anything if I'm going and I want a meal
there are eight items there to choose
from and none of them are hybrid items
how are the eight items how are they
eight items they give me all of that is
available to me that is the brunch
[ __ ] menu it is 27. it's weird that
one of the boxes that I say the eight
item says says brunch not nothing else
is
let's count on the sides let's count
bottles and cans okay hot fried chicken
honey butter biscuits and slaw breakfast
sandwich with Maple sausage egg and
cheese avocado toast with Jammy egg
salad and sunflower or mesco these are
all things that like aren't really on
there Black Angus hangers
and a farm I don't know that these
aren't on a regular menu Black Angus
hangers
that is the one thing that sounds like
it might not be on a lunch or breakfast
menu okay fried chicken with biscuits
and slaw yo yeah chicken and biscuits
wow what a wild concept oh you'd have to
go to Popeye's to find something like
that
chicken with biscuits on the side okay
and coleslaw too it's almost like we're
at KFC okay Brian Regan can you come
back to Joe DeRozan now and stop stop
getting less over Brian Regan I wasn't
doing reading you could have fooled me I
close my eyes I thought he was here okay
that's cool yeah hold on let me close my
eyes hold on let me close my eyes let me
close my eyes
budget better than ever and save money
you need rocket money do you know what
this is rocket money formally was known
as true bill is a personal finance app
that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending it
helps you lower your bills all in one
place we uh we use it I use this um I
signed up and I immediately canceled
three subscriptions I had a a New York
Times game subscription that I didn't
realize that I I bought in addition to
the actual
um news and then I had an apple game
subscription from like six months ago
that I forgot that I had and then I
found out that I had two Hulu accounts
which is insane because I think whatever
I would have never known that but as
soon as I downloaded it I hit one button
I canceled those apps I saved myself
like 25 bucks immediately per month
um over 80 percent of people have
subscriptions they forgot about
like the streaming service you bought to
watch just one show or that free trial
that you never even use which is exactly
what happened in my case rocket money
will quickly and easily identify your
subscriptions for you so you can stop
paying for the ones you don't want uh
they make cancelings the subscriptions
as easy as a click of the button which
is all I did simply find the
subscription you don't want hit cancel
they cancel it for you no more long hold
times of customer service or emailing
back and forth over three million people
have used rocket money
saving the average person up to 720
bucks per year yeah my click saved me
300 bucks immediately
um so stop throwing your money away
cancel unwanted subscriptions and manage
your expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com tastebuds that's
rocketmoney.com tastebuds this app is so
cool I don't know why it wasn't invented
a long time ago rocketmoney.com taste
buds
all right guys let's talk about butcher
box uh if you're a fan of the Pod you've
heard us talk about butcher box before I
got to tell you now that it's the winter
and also the new year I am prone to
staying in in these cold months and one
of my resolutions is to cook more
because it's relaxing me and I started
cooking I made a carrot cake over the
holiday and I also the other day made a
great uh grass-fed beef steak
um from butcher box I made it with some
potatoes and what else did I make it
with some um uh what do you call those
things pimp with the uh
the uh they look green and they're
little and uh I'm in Brussels sprouts
brussels sprouts yes
I made those life for me I'm not even a
great cook but it was really really good
butcher box takes the guesswork out of
finding high quality Meat and seafood
you can trust it's 100 grass-fed beef
free-range organic chicken pork raised
crate free wild caught Seafood they're
all humanely raised there's no
antibiotics no added hormones and that's
what is important to everyone these days
and they check every single box get just
what you want delivered right to your
doorstep it's free shipping in the
United States no surprise fees to
continental United States choose from a
variety of box plans from curated or
customized and you can change your plan
whenever you want
um
yeah high quality cuts that are hard to
come by at the grocery store at an
amazing value is what you're getting
here exclusive member deals you can save
big on your favorite cuts and there's
also a recipe inspiration guides tips
and hacks
um so you can uh you know for different
meals and stuff
I will tell you get the New Year bundle
for free plus ten dollars off when
you're signing up today that's a 14
ounce pork tenderloin two pounds of
ground turkey and four top sirloin
steaks in your first box sign up at
butcherbox.com Taste Buds and use the
code taste buds to claim the offer
I can't argue with someone who's
irrational right I'm not a rational pull
up another brunch when you put up the
show up another one this is this is
27 items can I tell him
can I make my can I make a point please
can you just entertain me no no no no no
a brunch menu is this a brunch menu is
things on that menu that are not
available on the other menus how do I
know those aren't available on the other
menu what a brunch menu is those
appetizers are available throughout the
week I promise you that brunch that's
what means that's why the brunch brunch
menu is not like that's why the prince
really want to know dishes that are a
hybrid that's the only thing that's
available for brunch ciao I you gotta
shut up for a second and listen to what
I'm saying to you all right no no no
stop you have to listen to me I just
listened brunch spots
now you have to listen to me
irrational [ __ ] look at me and
listen let me listen to it you the
appetizers and desserts are on the
normal menu the brunch item stop the
brunch items or the brunch items what I
asked you for 7 several times and you
have yet to be able to produce
there is yet to be something to prove me
wrong that a brunch menu is a handful of
breakfast things with a handful of lunch
things that you can get at breakfast or
lunch you cannot how do
you know because the definition of a
brunch menu is things that are on that
menu that they're preparing that day for
that window of time how is that is the
definition of a brunch menu how is that
that's the brunch menu the brunch menu
is things that are offered during brunch
it's not things that passed Joe de
Rose's test of when you mix an omelette
with a burger that's not what brunch
means brunch is this you is available at
this you claim there were hybrid dishes
we saw oneself a hybrid dish exists
there is I don't give a [ __ ] I need to
prove brunch that exactly I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] if the items
are served throughout the week or not
it's a handful of brunch lunch and my
items with a handful of breakfast I said
this isn't the one I go to though but uh
okay how about the croquet Monsieur
that's something we talked about on this
podcast before that's not available any
other time parmesan ham gruyere and egg
with tomatoes it's a breakfast item so
okay a breakfast item is a ham and
gruyere cheese sandwich with an egg and
a tomato soup no okay then it's a lunch
item uh you know it's a [ __ ]
breakfast [ __ ] both [ __ ] it's a
breakfast sandwich soup eggs ham it's
both congrats you found one hybrid dish
congrats now it's just oh it only took
you digging through now it's just a
sarcastic congrats when I point one out
you found one
look at me listen to me once again by
the way by the way pimp let's once again
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve these are your
appetizers
I have news for you appetizers are
served at brunch there's 19 things on
that menu so I promise you those
appetizers are available every day of
the week you are insane if you don't
promise you that a brunch menu is what's
on a brunch menu we gotta go to the
phones let's go to the phones you are
insane let's go to the [ __ ] insane
let's go to the phone by the way by the
way let's
none of that proves that brunch is not
good you talked over me and wasted our
time looking at menu this is a [ __ ]
battle bro battle and by the way by the
way remember remember before we started
when I said let's just get into the
battle you said no no we have to
[ __ ] and watch Tick Tock videos for
15 minutes I just said we don't want to
battle
straight minutes we would have we
I'm gonna have a closing argument this
is what Jody Rose has said about brunch
it's filled with people who don't like
each other arbitrary that don't like the
menu yep in ridiculous statements no I
didn't say don't like them anyways you
said people
they hate what's on the menu you said it
rewind back showed a clip yeah whatever
that's completely arbitrary and [ __ ]
then you said it has six items on the
menu yep we've proved you wrong first
two minutes we put up with 27 and 19
items respectively no no there was
appetizers from every other day with
eight available entrees and then you
said
screaming at me show me something that
is lunch and and and breakfast combined
because you kept swearing I showed you
one on each menu when I showed you it
you said great you found one everything
you said brunch let me say all the
things he said about happy hour
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] now I get to do
mine and keep quiet now I get to do mine
now I get to do mine I said that happy
hour brings co-workers together truth I
said that happy hour is a great time to
hang with your boys drink cheap beer
have quarter Wings whatever truth I said
that happy hour is a great way to kick
off Friday or Saturday night and brunch
is a way to to Stave off the [ __ ]
hangover from that truth truth truth
[ __ ] truth and I will stand by what I
said brunch was invented and utilized in
this city in particular to bring people
into the [ __ ] bar when nobody wants
to come in exactly the definition of
happy okay great here we go let's go to
the phones no but it's not that's not
what happy hour is that's your griper
brunch but then it you can't no I
admitted I said it was happy hour too
and why is it a gripe with brunch if
it's what you're because
let's go ours provides a meal the
substance you need for that day you
don't provide a meal you provide alcohol
people loaded my bar provides a meal
my bar provides a meal at happy hour we
have buy two get one free sandwiches wow
sandwich is a meal wow you must be like
copying brunch sandwich is a meal you
must be copied no we don't do a minute
wait a minute I don't serve the sandwich
with [ __ ] syrup wait you're serving
you're serving lunch sandwiches at
dinner
wow that's a novel concept I wonder what
other meal takes that and does and
applies that yeah you're serving
sandwiches we'll always serve as
sandwiches yeah at dinner though no we
serve sandwiches sandwiches are a dinner
food or a lunch food no they're not yes
they are no they're not that's a
different argument let's no they're not
the cold cut sandwich is not dinner okay
not traditionally maybe in Europe maybe
in your book and you know it not not
working
these are a staple of dinner where I
come from I want to go to a restaurant
that just serves cold cut sandwiches and
see if they call it a restaurant oh God
or it's a deli which one is it okay
which one is it okay look at yourself in
the mission yeah well you're the one
that invested in a dumb ass
that's the first true statement you said
all right
brunch brunch is for the elite come on
this holy [ __ ] this this needed to be no
matter what happens I love you this was
[ __ ] heavy there
I didn't expect this yeah he's a
perfectly sound thing the great thing
about brunch is you get bacon and drinks
happy hour is mostly just drinks happy
hour is for the cheap drinks and midday
fun brunches for cheap yet overpriced
sparkling wine that gives you a headache
okay don't drink it uh I couldn't
imagine ever waiting to go to brunch
wanting wanting okay brunch and alcohol
and Waffles chicken and waffles hybrid
[ __ ] hybrid or chicken and waffles well
chicken waffles is a southern it's a
hybrid that's it's not a brunch dish
it's a southern waffle of the breakfast
food
chicken is it lunch food
brunch for sure because you get to sleep
late no you don't you have to wake up at
9 30 to get to the goddamn place and get
a table by 11. no you don't brunchco is
still about two three o'clock at least
well that's not brunch anymore you're
into almost dinner time at three o'clock
that's insane not on a weekend
it's that that's that's that's that you
know come on meet me halfway on that
buddy I can't reinvent what brunch is
for you brunch is
brunch is a limited menu for a limited
time on Saturday and Sunday late
mornings to early afternoon thank you
that's what it is thank you a limited
menu meaning
you know as well as I do eleven to one
is your brunch hours you start to get
past 1 p.m and you're calling it brunch
in your in your heart or in the business
I'm just saying as far as meals brunch
is gonna go from like ten to three sure
and we do a happy hour for at my bar
from 10 p.m till midnight I don't
consider that I wouldn't use that in the
argument for this is my point you could
do a happy hour whatever you want you
what brunch is everywhere you're just
telling me that you don't like the fact
that brunch at three o'clock is no
longer brunch to you but I don't think
it goes till three o'clock everywhere
but that's my opinion but anyway it
doesn't matter chicken and waffles with
mimosas brunch baby 11 A.M Beach 5 p.m
thank you 11 A.M let's go back up one
second brunch is sophisticated nothing
is sophisticated about getting plastered
with your coworker because at 2 pm in
the afternoon at an apple that's not
true what happy hour is at 2 p.m with
your that's not true you know that
that's [ __ ] call [ __ ] when you
see it and I'll call [ __ ] when I see
that's what you just said you want to
get plastic with your co-workers I
didn't say that and it's not at 2PM what
[ __ ] happy hour is it 2 p.m there's
nothing better than day drinking except
day drinking with a nice snack it's
brunch all the way
after brunch you have pretty much the
whole there's something dry drinking is
one of the worst things ever of all time
after brunch you have pretty much the
whole day to do something after happy
hour you have a slight buzz in four plus
hours to diddle yourself oh I love that
that's on my front runner right yeah
yeah after happy hour you only have the
entire night to paint the [ __ ] town
and get it going okay
happy hour doesn't exist everywhere
there are actually laws against it in
Rhode Island where I live brunch is
everywhere and includes alcohol most of
the time especially Bloody Mary's but
now again another [ __ ] argument
brunch includes alcohol like like happy
hour doesn't
and like happy hour doesn't have food
happy hour serves like half-price
Burgers hold on listen to me food over
alcohol you're not listening to me I I'm
listening to the phone ciao you know as
well as I do plenty of happy hours serve
half price Burgers half price hot
sandwiches half price all kinds of [ __ ]
this argument that it's not all that
there's no food that is crazy it's not
just a bar bar you know if the bar
doesn't have food then no yes of course
but if a bar serves food they are giving
you a deal on that food
ugh
it is happy and the title brunch is the
mother-in-law's to feel Superior
uh your peasants you peasants and US
peasants of Massachusetts Massachusetts
can't enjoy the beauty
there is of a what
there's no way there's not right because
I like my waffles served with a side of
hot gas
Mimosa flights challah French toast
bacon ranch sliders for brunch all day
brunch has endless mimosas Bloody Marys
and Bellinis
I got to tell you bud everybody going
pro brunch is making the same point I
like to get stewed during the [ __ ]
day that's everybody's argument they're
working alcohol into every brunch
argument that I'm seeing here okay
because that's that's a component of it
but
wait that was not your argument is my
point so here's someone saying is there
a difference
thank you brunch brunch is joyful and
full of Hope for the day well happy hour
is full of complaining about the day oh
but that's an interesting point okay
that might be our winner that's just
such a Salient Point brunch menu is
better than a happy hour menu and I
would agree with that
look I can't argue that one of these
things is more of a restaurant
experience than the other it's just a
matter of which do you enjoy more I
enjoy a happy hour over a brunch any day
I hate bro I loathe
I mean Alex one
haven't been to happy hour since Walmart
required me to complete compete AAA in
order to keep my job
all right give it to this poor bastard
follow Alex
and it's spelled a the number one ex
third three two this is a nice closing
thing from Paul Dubois happy hour is
great and all but Sunday brunch Just
Hits different I think that's the words
we want to exit with today as we go to
the polls no we don't get to exit with
your choice of words brunch hits
different yeah it hits in the way that
you're so desperate you've brought
yourself to have a meal with these
[ __ ] people you're sitting with it is
Sex in the City a thousand percent Sex
in the City it's catty [ __ ] gossipy
let's drink a watermelon drink and talk
about who got fat that's brunch that's
not happy oh no happy hour
please get your penis off my foot happy
hour is let's get shit-faced and make a
few mistakes
like going to brunch all right um here
we go I would love for us to go to
brunch it would be great
I'll tell you what I'll go to both with
you
I've been a happy hour with you and
we'll compare notes but I'm going to
brunch with you great
so something good came out of it all
right good ready here we go who's the
winner where are you going here pimpy I
don't know where pimp would go here
7 000 votes and he's going happy hour
drum roll
oh wow yes it was close I did not think
that I was taking this one I really
thought happy hour was more popular I
thought happy hour would would win until
we went to the phones and I was like oh
[ __ ] I know me too yeah 7
votes up till right now we got it's
close even closer than last week yes
54.1 brunch to 45.9 happy hour We're
within five percent margin no we're just
over no no yeah it's almost within the
realm of a rematch so that that was that
was um great battle that was a very good
battle and I'm I'm happy to wear the
brunch
Crown right that was a good bad happy
full of my brunches out there I got you
back
uh I still love you babe I still love
you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds